à compter du 15 décembre le pas
salutaire pour les plus de 65 ans ne
sera plus actif si le rappelle n'a pas
été fait dans un délai de sept mois
après l'infection ou après la dernière
injection
et la compter du 15 janvier se passe
d'annie terre de tous les autres publics
ne sera plus actif si le rappelle n'a
pas été fait dans ce délai
il n'y aura pas d'impact de la troisième
dose sur le pass sanitaires c'est à dire
que si vous avez votre pass sanitaire
que vous aidiez que vous alliez prendre
votre rappel ou non vous garderez le
bénéfice du pass sanitaires
pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
n'intègre pas la troisième dose dans le
pass parce que le troisième dose n'a
rien à voir avec le pass aujourd'hui je
ne suis pas sûr que les autorités
sanitaires nous disent de mettre le
rappel dans le passé peut-être qu'ils
nous le dirons auquel cas on se posera
la question technique évidemment
[Musique]